[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
flo
[Musique]
et
le soleil
[Musique]
et
nous avons quitté madame l'api au moment
où toute fière d'avoir retrouvé le
bracelet de la petite suzy elle le
laissait tomber devant la porte du
fermier
et ce qu'elle avait prévu arrive le
fermier ouvre sa porte et voit le
bracelet
il reste un moment stupéfait et se met à
crier parce qu est ce que je vois qu'est
ce que ça veut dire un bracelet
disparaît il vient tout seul non bon on
se moque de qui ici je vais vous dressez
moi je suis trop gentil trop bon père ah
bah ça va pas se passer comme ça
et la petite fusée ravi d'avoir retrouvé
son joli bracelet chic mon bracelet que
je suis contente
[Musique]
les madame l'api joyeuse et fier de sa
bonne action sautille de contentement
sur sa branche
cependant elle s'aperçoit que le fermier
la regardent d'un oeil soupçonneux
[Musique]
pékin regard fillon vite
la voilà la reconnaissance des hommes
s'étaient hissés vers et soupçonneux
encore un peu il m'aurait accusé au on
ne sait jamais il soutiendra et dire que
c'est moi qui rapportait le bracelet est
bine soyez honnête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et dès le lendemain madame l'api raconte
à tous à tout le monde et à sa façon
[Musique]
alors je vis le bracelet de la petite
suzy c'était ces vilains une poule qui
l'avait pris évidemment cette petite
saute de blanchette que je n'avais
jamais remarqué si petit
une gamine quoi et bien c'est elle c'est
elle qui jouait les plus bracelet à qui
se fier grand dieu mais c'est à peine
croyable et le fermier et les enfants il
était content je pense
le fermier c'était incroyable je ne vais
jamais vu aussi ému il ne cessait de
répéter merci madame pays merci madame
pitt sans vous que serions nous devenus
c'est vrai en quel brave homme ce
fermier au fond sous ses airs bourrus
c'est un grand coeur oui pour un grand
coeur c'est un grand coeur c'est dommage
qu'il ne montre pas assez
enfin moi je suis contente tout le
poulailler c'est que je suis innocente
[Musique]
et maintenant toute la forêt elle sait
aussi ce n'est que justice
[Musique]
cocorico
il
sept ans
[Musique]